great big story we in here
mama we made it
everybody always say that i think it's
better my mom's
i think my grandma couldn't even do this
they think we we got our grandmas
cooking for us
no this is us we did that like yeah a
young man
trap is is take risks and prosper and
that's what we're doing here so that's
what we use trap kitchen 15 shrimps in
the bag man trap kitchen is this a spot
where you prepare products to be
distributed underground we just use that
mentality with food we're a full-blown
catering service and you also can order
for delivery during the week my team
consists of myself and three other guys
i call them my brothers my boy a wall um
dj kev and bad news we're a small team
but we get the job done all the time you
know i mean we always crips and bloods
you know i mean doing that kind of stuff
of course i'm getting arrested every
other day for nothing they're shooting
at us so
now the only thing we worried about is
some food burning up like or running out
that's it
i was talking to my mom she's like you
got to do something son i'm like okay
well what can i do i've seen the corner
blue commercial on tv i'm like damn that
look kind of cool i could probably do
something with that i know like you can
make good money cooking
i moved to vegas started culinary school
and that's where
i began to practice
my craft you know
he really came in here from vegas he
like broke what we gonna do like we need
some money i said wait we can sell some
food through instagram i was like
posting my food and people was like oh
that looks so good that looks great and
i like okay now it's time for me to
offer this food to the streets like how
a d-boy pushes dope you know what i'm
saying
it worked
the key to our success
we never gave up man every day that's
all i think about is how can we improve
our company how can we improve our food
how can we improve the taste
even though i'm reading the house
trapping i feel like it's a real
restaurant
you